[Music]
despite keeping their rumoured
relationship under wraps Justin Bieber
packs on the PDA with Haley Baldwin
here's the pair walking hand-in-hand
while leaving dinner at cheap Rihanna's
in New York City on Thursday Bieber and
Baldwin rocked coordinating black
outfits before what looks like a low-key
date night the sorry singer kept things
casual in a shirt basketball shorts and
snapback cap while the 21 year old model
looked edgy with an oversized leather
jacket and braids and eyewitness spot at
the duo sharing a dessert at the
restaurant
Haley opted for a spoon to eat a cake
while Justin got down and dirty using
his finger and licking the frosting off
I'm having a good time
the Biebs and Baldwin have yet to speak
out about their relationship but have
been spotted getting cozy in recent
weeks back in 2016 Baldwin gushed to et
about the popstar her then boyfriend
he's really funny we have a good time
together he's just really sweet he's a
good kid he's a good heart and I love
[Music]
[Applause]